yeah I went to welcome to city ok I'll
penquin the city allow us to glencoe and
i'm not mistaken i should have had some
games against them there is one of those
guys check this is immensely popular I
don't really know why I get this pretty
quick pretty frequently always see like
if widest fighting in a fryer I don't
want to take their yeah I wonder if six
is actually good here or not taking is
definitely wrong that is giving the Dead
Set problematic but ok let's develop
navel Wow why it isn't a fan of quick
development it seems so I'm going to
bust this open now so I can even take
with the pawn shooting for me shooting
for on d5 that's very aggressive this
should take this is good though so let's
take with the bishop just developing
quickly
yeah 25 next castles define context 95
yeah ok that's ok for Blackie i'm not
sure if it is better than that but i
think i can can be happy d for NC 3r
good squares the ape one isn't doing
anything soon now let's see three i
think is actually a threat
okay now I still do this at home on c3
is going to be very dangerous I've got
nice before coming it's a big threat
yeah okay but look here I mean this is
all nice and good but still after night
before why do cats no squares so i can
even simply sacrifice the exchange i
think let's do it
the sea pawn in connection with the
night is certainly worth the exchange he
has to take a 80 I think well actually I
can I can't take the one this is the
thing I can take the one hand take the
one and then it could be even stronger
[Music]
but if i take here and this is i have
looped the eight next I mean let's say
yeah this and now I love t8 let's set
position is just great 93 is something
yeah 93 a bishop deform let's jump in
porn is always very nicely covered by
the bishop you look before as possible
no let's do it can you think about this
one admittedly
okay now my loop here is protected and
not hanging anymore so if I check so I
mean that that looks nice but how do I
actually make something happen maybe
queen bee seven trying to take Bay three
[Music]
that's possible so if i take what is he
doing can also take them
and just just training Queens is also
fine I mean I'm really okay after the
Queen trade ok ty money ok I wanted to
play rupees heaven with nite nite 285 is
somewhat irritating it really is all
right I've got a sixth and ok p6 I look
a sexist is a threat however then
they've got 97 so this isn't clear so
then take it that wasn't the plan but I
need to speak to solve ok yeah I have to
disposition I don't really love this and
what such a great position and now I'm
struggling with no time
this isn't even good chair check check
five seconds yeah game wrong okay hello
it's okay yeah my choice is not enough
from what I had between the thing I
should also have profited of course yeah
this is so this is just fantastic for
black iron 94 is winning already is that
this is also fantastic so night a 2 is
winning this is also good not as good
don't worry but still I can't believe
that I got a loss position from this
here Queen the 724 and should be for now
this should be for King ash one night f2
yeah I was just thinking as it should be
enough and is enough should give orders
just came we should be 3z to and
promotes and this night f2 just winter
so I just can't keep missing simple
witnessing from right to the ship and
yeah I should just young position but
sir well he was just focusing on living
on time and she didn't really look
anymore okay gentlemen here it's winning
but I've got four seconds so okay well
thanks for watching